good to see you thank you sir
absolutely all right come on the Paris
agreement ended up being a historic
agreement not because it gets us to
where we need to be eventually but for
the first time locking in all countries
into verifiable steps and targets that
they're gonna take it creates the
architecture that allows us to finally
start dealing with this problem in a
serious way so you were happy with I was
happy that we put the architecture in
place big the targets that have been set
in Paris are nowhere near enough for
what the scientists tell us we have to
do eventually to solve this problem but
if we can use the next 20 years to apply
existing technologies to reduce carbon
emissions and then start slowly turning
up the dials as new technologies come
online so that we have more and more
ambitious targets each year then we're
not going to completely reverse the
warming that now is inevitable but we
can stop it before it becomes
catastrophic it's no secret that you've
been under great opposition to try to
implement some of your climate change
initiatives and so somebody that comes
into office that does not believe in the
science of climate change right do they
have the capacity and the power to
dismantle everything that you've already
worked for even if somebody came in
campaigning on denying climate science
reality has a way of yeah hynnyín in the
nose if you're if you're not paying
attention and I think that the public is
starting to realize the science in part
because it's indisputable I admire your
optimism yeah but you start to look at
the science look at what's going on in
the Antarctic uns and scientists saying
that there are sections of ice that
guarantee four to six meters of ocean
level rise which will be catastrophic
for the future you are the leader of the
free world you have access to
information not that most people do not
what makes you terrified for the future
a huge portion of the world's population
lives near oceans mm-hmm
if they start moving then you start
seeing scarce resources the subject to
competition between populations mm-hmm
this is the reason why the Pentagon has
said this is a national security issue
this isn't just an environmental issue
there's a national security issue you
know in addition to just the sadness
that I would feel if my kids can never
see a glacier the way I saw when I went
up to Alaska yeah that's the romantic
side of me that's the side that takes a
walk with my daughters and I want to be
able to them to see or my grandkids I
want them to see the same things I saw
as I was growing up even if you were
unsentimental about that in very
hard-headed terms you've got to worry
about the national security implications
of this and the capacity for the
existing World Order as we understand it
to survive the kinds of strains that the
scientists are predicting with that
action this is why we have to take
action now